let's take this call see what we got hey
Theo my name's Grace I'm Grace I love
that
I love that
and some people at different churches
they don't respect people from other
churches and that is called gracism
when people have gracism they don't want
they ain't offering Grace to everybody
no they're not so onward an Alabama girl
but currently living in Hawaii and I'm
actually coming to your show in
Chattanooga and bringing my Filipino
boyfriend with me oh damn boy
mommy popping that Pinot out huh
that Filipino and I've always wanted to
create a wine called Filipino Grigio
and how that hasn't been done
and how that you know that that there's
not a Pinot out there
a Filipino Filipino
how there's not a Filipino
hey Filipinos hey hey hey hey some kids
they they did they confuse jalapenos and
Filipinos you know they're like hey give
me I want the hot dog with
um a couple of Filipinos on it huh
you know some people are like yeah I
want that hot dog with the uh put two uh
put you you know a couple of them
Filipinos on there
hey bro hey hey hey
let me get a hot dog with uh
you know put someone in Filipinos on
their bid Pinos on that [__]
okay sorry ma'am I'm losing it today I
was in the cold plunge earlier could be
real honest and so I'm [__]
I'm feeling alive and I'm grateful for
that
um and then we're going to go down to
Alabama to visit my family but what's
the best way to introduce my Filipino
boyfriend to my family everybody's very
white and um
I don't know I'm super nervous about the
whole I guess interracial thing as bad
as that sounds like my family's not
racist but still just like a different
culture oh yeah I know what you mean
honey
yeah it's not it's just date a little
bit of daytime racism maybe what you're
talking about that's nothing you know
nothing violent nothing crazy just you
know every now and then you know it's
like you got something stuck in your
teeth you didn't even have any meat but
you just have
they're like what is that damn
is that an inward you know I'm saying
you just you don't know sometimes you're
like
that hat you know that's from previous
culture sometimes we still get things
stuck in our teeth uh just because other
people been
having beef you know
um
but yeah I think the best way probably
to introduce a Filipino to some whites
well uh I would do a
uh ethnicity reveal where you put them
in a box or put them behind a tree
um and then you let your family guess
what ethnicity is going to be
and then get one of those smoke things
and maybe it makes
I don't want to say yellow smoke I mean
that's you can't do that that's racist
um
just you know what don't do the smoke
thing have him come out from behind the
tree
and say here he is
uh
yeah but if people guess make sure they
don't guess anything real racist that's
that's going to be uncomfortable you
know so but yeah I think you can handle
it and I'm excited for you guys and
you know I think having a little Asian
baby is beautiful
you know I have to I used to have a lot
of dreams and there were Asian children
in them
and nothing was illegal in it and it was
uh
it was
it was cool man
you know there's just something about an
Asian Where You Are
you want to just you wanna
you wanna do that to him boy you want to
get it right up volume hey buddy
I love you I love you you want to treat
them well so but no I appreciate it and
I think uh
yeah and Filipinos for they are the
um
I mean they're just so good
they're so good
I read somewhere
I think it was graffiti or somebody was
like if you break open God's heart
that there's probably 30 Filipinos in
there
splitting an orange
or just dividing up a bag of fruit or
something hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one or
this one